буде чергова ганьба яйцпі 17
бізнесвирощування коноплі Я дуже
здивована друзі Всіх вітаю це остання
пленарне засідання важкого 23го
року будь ласка йдемо далі Ну як завжди
от в останній ці місяці під час
головування стефанчука Верховна Рада
працює в пленарному режимі в місяць
3-4ри дні надалі потенціалу услуг немає
вони розходяться розбігаються І
перетрудилися що звичайно не нормально
Дякую усім за плідну роботу Але тим не
менш сьогодні був цікавий день і
найбільш скандальним голосуванням була
спроба протягти на посаду голови
рахункової палати таку собі Ольгу
піщанську скандально відому сусідку
родини зеленських по парадному в Кривому
Розі просто щоб зробити головою
рахункової палати цю піщанську наближену
до родини зеленських на її сестру
оформлена Віла родини на що це все
робити буде чергова ганьба до цього пані
піщанська вже очолювала Антимонопольний
комітет коли вона не помічала там
монополій олігархічних якщо мова йшла
про олігархів близьких до офісу
президента кінець епохи кумавства настав
Вітаю всіх вас тепер її вирішили
поставити
контролером на дуже важливу посаду Кожен
член рахункової палати має мати
грунтовні знання щодо фінансових всіх
законів тому і зараз коли ви намагаєтесь
притягувати людей які будуть пособниками
фальсифікації висновків Я дуже здивована
рахункова палата
вонади проводить моніторинг і
використання бюджетних коштів державних
установ і коштів звичайно наших
міжнародних партнерів А з чим же
пов'язана атака на рахункову палату
рахункова палата вскрила корупцію в
міністерстві оборони рахункова палата
найшла і підтвердила яйця пі 17 40 млрдв
дебіторки рахункова палата скрила
корупцію з телесіріалами рахункова
палата вскриває і вскриває і на
сьогоднішній день цим голосуванням їм
хотяти закрити рота там треба звичайно
своя людина а це попри те що наші
міжнародні партнери посли G7 зробили
публічну заяву з закликом до української
влади слухайте нам допомагають весь світ
допомагають партнери Вони звертаються до
нас з проханням проведіть ці голосування
оберіть нових членів рахункової палати
тільки після того як буде проведе будуть
прийняті нові закони і на базі цих
законів буде проведено прозорий чесний
конкурс А ми що говоримо нам наплівать
Ну ви що робите взагалі але прийняли тут
же стефанчук оголосив засідання
бюджетного комітету прямо під час
пленарного засідання які проголосував за
обрання пані щанської хотілося почути
підтвердження від голови комітету що
засідання комітету відбулось тому що
більша частина членів комітету
знаходилась в залі і голосувала але
навіть серед слух Мабуть що не було
багато бажаючих голосувати за цей
непотизм адже Зеленський обіцяв
покінчити з кумавством і нічого не
говорив про сусідівство І от Подивіться
стефанчук був змушений провести
сигнальне
голосування за
і вони побоялися виносити в цілому оце
кадрове питання на голосування сусідка
пішла з зали не
обрана Шановні колеги На жаль ми не
встигли розглянути всі питання порядку
денного Дякую усім за плідну роботу
зараз я Оголошую перерву у нашому
пленарному засіданні друзі ще одне
скандальне голосування сьогодні Верховна
Рада України легалізувала медичний
канабіс за 240
рішення прийнято Закон прийнятий в
цілому це в основному слуги голос і опзж
європейська Солідарність яка в першому
читанні підтримала цей законопроект з
вимогою допрацювати його до другого
читання і прийняти наші поправки була
змушена утриматися жодна з наших
поправок комітетом на жаль врахована не
була Тарас Ратушний батько героя Романа
ратушного який служить в Збройних Силах
і є лідером однієї з громадських
організацій яка підтримує використання
канабісу звернувся до депутатів з
вимогою оскільки цей закон не є
досконалим відправити його на повторне
друге читання І от ми звичайно як
фракція яка дуже активно співпрацює з
неурядовим сектором з громадськими
активістами дослухалися тут до їх
пропозицій закликали залу направити цей
законопроект на повторне друге читання
адже На жаль до другого читання він не
покращився Там є дуже багато за
взаємозаперечливих норм це дає на на
розсуд там слідчих органів
поліції вести потім рішення можна було в
такому випадку його застосовувати чи ні
а отже це буде величезне поле для
корупції ми будемо наполягати на тому
щоб привести цей закон забрати з нього
всі суперечності зробити його ефективним
і нарешті допомогти нашим пацієнтам а не
імітувати допомогу пацієнтам в законі
який насправді про бізнес вирощування
коноплі налагодити українське
виробництво ліків з медичним канабісом
можливо буде Через роки але коноплю
почнуть вирощувати в промислових
масштабах прямо зараз і ми переживаємо
що в цьому законі не має чітких
регуляцій оціого державного регулювання
ємо що якщо не приймаються наші поправки
які комітет визнавав правильними
професійними але вони ну заважали тут
лобізму кількох фірмочок які сядуть на
потоки оцього от виробництва канабісу їх
не було прийнято тому ми утрималися
шановна Ірина Володимирівна ще раз
підвер що біль більшість поправок від
вашої фракції були дійсно фахові
парламент сьогодні ратифікував кілька
дуже важливих міжнародних угод
європейська Солідарність буде голосувати
за в той же час якщо ми говоримо про
Азію очевидно що з країнами глобального
півдня ми маємо сьогодні працювати
активніше Тому що сьогодні Росія дуже
активно працює з глобальним півднем і
через ці країни знаходить
імпортозаміщення товарів подвійного
призначення які ідуть потім на військові
потреби і саме в цьому контексті має
бути зосереджена і робота наших
дипломатів і міжпарламентська дипломатія
і очевидно що команда європейської
солідарності на всіх міжнародних
зустрічах активно піднімає питання
санкцій і дуже прикро що наша
міжпарламентська діяльність блокується
що представники європейської
солідарності які точно назовні працюють
під одним прапором українським на жаль
не можуть в повній мірі використовувати
наші контакти наші зв'язки нашу
професійність наші можливості аби разом
робити все для того аби посилити
відповідальність Російської Федерації не
завтра А сьогодні до речі його чекають
судові позови степаанчука щодо
блокування наших відряджень в чому
проблема Шановні колеги будь ласка
зупиніться Ну і найганебніше це те що
голова Верховної Ради і його заступники
знову не зачитали запити народних
депутатів це вже три місяці коли під час
пленарних засідань ну рідких знаєте як
не знаю як сонечко в Холодні осінні дні
у нас не знаходиться часу зачитати
депутатські запити до органів влади до
уряду А це важливий механізм
парламентського контролю Ну все як
завжди Можливо тому що серед цих Запитів
є і до нього запити щодо фінансування
Верховної Ради України щодо того як
формуються оці делегації також важливо
відзначити що в чергове
провалена година запитань до уряду
колеги
Схаменіться Ну що ви робите друзі
нагадаю що ми працювали не лише активно
депутатами і в залі і в комітетах і в
регіонах а і з Олексієм Гончаренко
Олексій підійди до мене будь ласка Ми з
тобою працювали парламентськими
кореспондентами адже канал Рада на який
щороку йде 170 млн грн а це Вибачте
тисячі безпілот якиййде 2 мільрди
абсолютно А це безпілотники дрони
реабілітація наших поранених і вони не
показують засідань парламенту От навіщо
А ми тепер ми знаємо навіщо Для того щоб
люди не бачили цю
ганьбу Шановні колеги На жаль ми не
встигли розглянути всі питання порядку
денного я хочу подякувати Олексію який
виконував по суті роль каналу рада
марафону безкоштовно не за 170 грн
навіть не те що 170 тисячі мільйонів А
ми тепер журналісти дорогі підставили
вам пле ви тепер хоч можете бачити це
власними очима тому псь Підписуйтесь на
tiktok Олексія на мій YouTube канал
обов'язково обов'язково на наші всі
соцмережі тому що тут багато Правди
багато і ви просто бачите все своїми
очима ви можете не погоджуватись з нашим
коментарем але ви хоч побачите і зробити
свої висновки А щоб ніхто то вам
розповідав потім Балочки абсолютно друзі
і так як це останній пленарний день
цього важкого 23го року то від всіх нас
Дозвольте подякувати всім що тримали
міцно Україну в першу чергу збройним
силам України Дякуємо за службу Дякуємо
за службу Дорогі наші Чоловіки і жінки в
Збройних силах України ми усвідомлюємо
нашу відповідальність боротися за вас в
цій залі і назовні для того щоби була
фінансування було підтримка було більше
снарядів і Дозвольте всім нам побажати
аби 24-й рік приніс нам таку
довгоочікувану таку важливу таку важку
перемогу все буде Україна друзі Слава
Україні